let's go next to our caller from the
six-30 area code who's calling today
from six-30 does that mean
yes it is hey Dave this is Reuben and I
want to congratulate you on almost
crossing 800,000 subscribers thank you
so much I appreciate it so I have a
question when it comes to hip hop okay
so out of the three hip hop artists who
would you choose personally Tupac or
notorious BIG known as biggie
yep for easy I would go with Tupac
myself I mean it's a it's it's pretty
cut and dry yeah I would I absolutely
agree even though I like them all and
the majority of the new hip hop artists
who I would choose Tupac out of all out
of all the hip hop artists I'm less
familiar with easy ease material and I
don't want to make it seem like I think
Tupac is orders of magnitude greater
than notorious b.i.g but I do think that
for me the decision is clear yeah I've
listened eazy-e but I said his songs are
pretty amazing but I think soo bahk is
way better than easy
alright well he's like wait you've
you've drawn a line in the sand and we
will see how the audience reacts alright
sure no problem thank you for the
quality and I having other things HAP
happy new year as well thank you so much